.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
WE'RE GETTING NEW INFORMATION IN
A TRAGIC MISTAKE ROCKING
HOLLYWOOD.
ALEC BALDWIN ACCIDENTALLY
SHOEDING DEAD HALYNA HUTCHINS
AND WOUNDING THE DIRECTOR AFTER
FIRING OFF A SHOT FROM THE PROP
GUN FROM THE SET OF HIS MOVIE IN
NEW MEXICO.
WITNESSES SAID BALDWIN WAS
ASKING PEOPLE AROUND HIM WHY HE
WAS HANDED A HOT GUN.
EVERYBODY NOW WONDERING HOW THIS
COULD HAVE HAPPENED.
PROP MASTER'S UNION REPORTEDLY
SAYING THERE WAS A LIVE ROUND IN
THE GUN BALDWIN FIRED.
THE L.A. TIMES REPORTING THE
PROP GUN MISFIRED DAYS BEFORE
THE ACCIDENT AND THE CAMERA CREW
HAD PREVIOUSLY WALKED OFF THE
SET OVER UNSAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS.
THE ACTOR TWEETING OUT A
STATEMENT SAYING THERE'S NO
WORDS TO CONVEY HIS SHOCK AND
SADNESS REGARDING THE TRAGIC
ACCIDENT AND THAT HIS HEART IS
BROKEN FOR THE FAMILY OF
HUTCHINS.
BALDWIN WAS QUESTIONED BY POLICE
AND RELEASED WITHOUT ANY CHARGES
BEING FILED.
THE SANTA FE SHERIFF I'VE OFFICE
SAYS THE INVESTIGATION IS OPEN
AND ACTIVE AND WITNESSES ARE
BEING INTERVIEWED.
GREG, THIS IS A CRAZY STORY
OBVIOUSLY.
A LOT OF PROTOCOLS WERE NOT
FOLLOWED TO HAVE SOMETHING LIKE
THIS HAPPEN.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A HUGE
INVESTIGATION AND POTENTIAL
MAMMOTH INSURANCE PAY-OUT
AFTERWARDS.
>> Greg: HE'S NOT JUST THE ACTOR
IN THIS.
HE'S THE PRODUCER.
SO HE'S GOT A LOT ON THE LINE
HERE.
RIGHT NOW I'M GOING THROUGH GOOD
GREG BAD GREG.
>> Jesse: TAKE YOUR TIME.
>> Dana: WHAT DOES GOOD GREG
SAY?
>> Greg: GOOD GREG SAYS -- HE
FEELS THIS.
THAT I FEEL ABSOLUTELY AWFUL FOR
THE VICTIM'S FAMILY.
I FEEL AWFUL FOR ALEC BALDWIN.
I CAN'T IMAGINE HOR 'DOURVES  --
HOW HORRIBLE IT WILL.
HE WILL BE KNOWN FOR THIS THE
REST OF HIS LIFE.
BAD GREG SAYS IF ANYONE OF US
HAD ACCIDENTSLY SHOT AND KILLED
SOMEONE OR A POLICE OFFICER, HE
WOULD BE ALL OVER IT.
HE WOULD SHOW NO SUCH
COMPASSION.
WE KNOW THAT HE'S DONE THAT TO
POLICE OFFICERS ONLINE.
HE WOULD DESTROY US.
THAT'S BAD GREG.
SO GOOD GREG IS GOING TO SAY
OKAY, THIS IS ABOUT TRAINING.
THIS IS ABOUT VIOLATING THE
GOLDEN RULES OF HANDLING GUNS.
ONE, YOU ALWAYS POINT IT IN THE
SAFE DIRECTION AND NUMBER 2,
YOUR FINGER IS ALWAYS OFF THE
TRIGGER, THIS GOES IN MOVIES AND
KEEP IF GUN UNLOADED UNTIL YOU
USE IT AND TREAT ALL GUNS AS
THOUGH THEY'RE LOADED.
THAT'S WHAT I LEARNED FROM MY
NRA TRAINING.
I LEARNED THOSE THINGS.
AS A NEUROTIC, I'M A VERY GOOD
GUN OWNER.
SO WHAT MIGHT HAVE CAUSED THIS?
CARELESSNESS AND PROBABLY
COMFORT IN THE SENSE THAT YOU'RE
IN THIS LAND OF MAKE BELIEVE SO
YOU FORGET THE PROTOCOLS.
REALLY INTERESTING HYPOCRISY IN
HOLLYWOOD.
A LACK OF RESPECT FOR GUNS BY
THE CHARACTERS THAT THE ACTORS
ARE PLAYING.
RIGHT?
THERE'S NEVER ANY RECOIL.
THEY'RE ALWAYS POINTING THE GUN
LIKE THIS.
THIS IS NOT A REALISTIC GUN
PRACTICE.
SO THE HYPOCRISY IS, PEOPLE IN
MOVIES PROPAGATE UNSAFE GUN
PRACTICES WHILE CONDEMNING THE
NRA, WHICH PUSHES SAFE GUN
PRACTICES.
SO YOU HAVE THIS -- YOU ARE
EITHER PRO GUN CONTROL OR YOU'RE
EVIL THAT PREVENTS YOU FROM
BENEFITTING FROM YOUR
ADVERSARIES TRAINING.
TRAINING FROM THE SWORN ENEMY,
THE NRA, WOULD HAVE PREVENTED
THIS.
IF YOU HAD ACTUAL NRA TRAINING,
THIS WOULDN'T HAVE HAPPENED.
I DOUBT ALEC BALDWIN HAD ANY NRA
TRAINING.
HAVING SAID THAT, I FEEL AWFUL
ABOUT IT.
>> Jesse: WHAT DOES GOOD KENNEDY
AND BAD KENNEDY HAVE TO SAY
ABOUT THIS?
>> I SHARE GREG'S REMORSE FOR
THIS.
I FEEL REALLY BAD FOR THAT
WOMAN'S FAMILY.
SHE'S GOING TO WORK.
SHE'S A REAL BAD ASS, A WOMAN IN
A MALE DOMINATED PROFESSION,
WITH A SON AND A HUSBAND.
YOU THINK IT'S GOING TO BE SAFE.
YOU'RE GOING ON LOCATION.
IT'S PRETTY WROTE.
THEN SHE LOSES HER LIFE.
THAT'S GOOD KENNEDY.
I'M PIGGYBACKING ON GOOD GREG.
IT'S FRIDAY.
PIGGYBACKING IS FUN.
BUT BAD KENNEDY ASKS, WHO KILLED
THIS WOMAN?
DID THE GUN KILL THIS WOMAN OR
DID ALEC BALDWIN KILL THIS
WOMAN?
THAT ULTIMATELY WILL BE THE
QUESTION WHEN THE LAWSUITS ARE
FILED?
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE HERE?
IT'S VERY INTERESTING.
I KNOW DAGEN CAN SPEAK TO THIS
IN GREATER DETAIL.
THIS IS PART OF A HUGE UNION
FIGHT.
THE UNIONS WILL SAY IF YOU HAD
MORE UNION INVOLVEMENT, THIS
WOULD BE SAFER.
UNIONS MAKE EVERYTHING BETTER.
WE KNOW THAT IS NOT NECESSARILY
THE CASE ESPECIALLY FOR THINGS
LIKE TEACHER'S UNIONS AND EVERY
OTHER PUBLIC SECTOR UNION.
THAT WILL BE THE THRUST OF A
MASSIVE FIGHT ASIDE FROM THE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE DIRECTLY
ASKED OF THIS CASE.
>> Jesse: YEAH, THEY HAVE TO
FIND OUT WERE WELL-TRAINED,
WELL-ORGANIZED UNION MEMBERS
RESPONSIBLE FOR HANDLING THIS
WEAPON APPROPRIATELY AND DID
THEY LEAVE OR WERE THEY FIRED,
DID THEY WALK OFF THE SET
BECAUSE OF THIS BROUHAHA OVER
COST CUTTING.
WITH ALL OF THIS STUFF NOT
THERE, DID A MISTAKE HAPPEN?
>> THE L.A. TIMES IS REPORTING
THAT THE CAMERA CREW MEMBERS OF
THE INTERNATIONAL ALLIANCE OF
THEATRICAL STAGE EMPLOYEES
SPENT -- THEY WALKED OFF THE
SET.
IT APPEARS AS IF THERE WERE
CERTAINLY NONUNION WORKERS
FILLING IN.
SO AGAIN, WERE THE STANDARD
SAFETY PROTOCOLS BEING FOLLOWED
BY THE PROP MASTER, THE STUNT
COORDINATOR AND THE LIKE.
BUT THE UNION IS ALREADY IN A
HUGE CONTRACT FIGHT WITH THE
STUDIO.
SO IT DOES RAISE THE ATTENTION
AND LEVEL OF OUTRAGE BASED ON
THOSE UNION MEMBERS ABOUT WHAT
IS GOING ON, BUT SPEAKING OF GUN
CONTROL, WHEN THESE HORRIBLE
ACCIDENTS HAPPEN, I ALWAYS WAKE
UP AND THINK, WHO IS GOING TO
WEIGH-IN ON SOCIAL MEDIA FOR
THEIR OWN BENEFIT FOR ATTENTION
TO BLOAT THEIR OWN EGO, TO FEED
THEIR OWN NARCISSISM?
GUESS WHO IT WAS?
GUN CONTROL ADVOCATES.
THEY HIT THE TWITTER SPHERE
TRYING TO EXPLOIT THIS TRAGEDY
FOR AGAIN, THEIR OWN AGENDA.
THIS IS A WORKPLACE ACCIDENT.
NONE OF THEIR IDEAS ON
RESTRICTING GUN OWNERSHIP OR
DISMANTLING ABOLISHING THE
SECOND AMENDMENT WOULD PREVENT
THIS TRAGIC ACCIDENT FROM
HAPPENING.
IT'S NEGLIGENCE.
BASED ON WHAT WE KNOW IT LOOKS
LIKE NEGLIGENCE.
BUT THERE JUST SEEMS GROSS.
IT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE
ANYBODY'S MIND ABOUT GUN
CONTROL.
BUT HERE'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF
WHAT I SAW.
FRANCIS FISHER IS ONE OF THE
STARS ON THIS MOVIE.
SHE RETWEETED THIS TWEET FROM
SHANNON WATTS OF MOM'S DEMANDS.
SHE WAS QUOTING A DAILY BEAST
ARTICLES.
FRANCIS FISHER SAID THE QUOTES
ARE INACCURATE.
OUR DIRECTOR IS ALREADY OUT OF
THE HOSPITAL.
SHE SAID HE WAS IN INTENSIVE
CARE.
I DON'T SUBSCRIBE TO THE DAILY
BEAST, SO IF THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING, THEY'RE WRONG.
CAN YOU CORRECT THEM?
AGAIN, IT'S THE RUSH TO MAKE
THIS ACCIDENT, THIS DEATH ABOUT
GUN CONTROL AND IT JUST RAISES
THE ISSUE OF LIKE WHAT EVER
HAPPENED TO HAVING SOME GRACE
AND JUST SHUTTING THE HELL UP?
IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO SAY
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS, DON'T SAY
ANYTHING.
SOMETHING THAT IS ROUNDLY MOCKED
BY THE LEFT.
>> Jesse: JESSICA?
>> THERE WERE UNPALATABLE TWEETS
FROM BOTH SIDES.
J.D. VANCE, A SENATOR FROM OHIO
SAID DISGUSTING TWEETEDS.
IT'S NOT A TIME FOR THAT BECAUSE
THIS WAS A WORKPLACE ACCIDENT.
I'M CURIOUS TO SEE WHAT ALEC
BALDWIN'S ROLE AS A PRODUCER
DOES IN TERMS OF COMPLICATING
THE SITUATION FOR HIM.
I GREW UP GOING TO MOVIE SET A
LOT.
MY DAD WAS A PRODUCER.
I NOTICED FROM THE AGE OF 7 WHEN
I WAS COGNIZANT OF WHAT WAS
GOING ON, HOW NERVOUS THE ACTORS
WERE AROUND GUNS TO MAKE SURE
EVERYTHING WAS FINE BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT FIREARMS EXPERTS.
THEY HAVE NOT HAD TRAINING IN
THIS.
YOU RELY ON THE PEOPLE, THE
UNION FOLKS OR THE PRIVATE
HANDLERS TO ASSURE THAT IT'S
SAFE.
THIS IDEA THAT THERE WERE REAL
BULLETS IN THERE AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT CAN HAPPEN
BEFORE AND IT WAS BRANDON LEE
WAS THE LAST TIME SOMEONE DIED
ON A SET, 1993, IN "THE CROW".
>> Greg: THE BLANK COMES OUT AT
THE SAME SPEED.
>> HE DID AFTER SIX HOURS OF
SURGERY.
>> WHAT HAPPENS, THERE'S A SQUIB
IN THE GUN THAT LOOKS LIGHTS A
REAL BULLET.
IT DOESN'T -- IT HAS THE POWER
REMOVED FROM IT.
THERE WAS A FRAGMENT FROM THE
SQUIB IN THE GUN AND THEN THEY
USED A BLANK, WHICH IS A FULL
CHARGE, NO LEAD.
SO THE CHARGE SEN